what's up everyone on Mike McCarty here
at Gamescom 2016 we're talking dead
rising for I have gotten the chance to
play it a few times but Scott you got
the first look at the campaign today
yeah actually when they did a full
presentation kind of getting into some
of the lighter aspects of the campaign
or they can go too deep into it but I
know a little bit more than we did
before yeah it stars Frank West you
slightly older still a photojournalist
takes place in wilmette Colorado again
the side of the first game although now
it includes the surrounding area in
addition to the original mall so a lot
of that stuff is already established but
I did get to learn a little bit more
about the game to learn more about
what's being added importantly the
photography stuff does come back Frank
is bringing target back with him it
works a little differently now though
you can still just take pictures stuff
and get points and earn things that way
but there are also some camera modes
like there's a night vision mode so if
you're in a dark area you can be looking
through the viewfinder and being like
first person so you're kind of
defenseless and don't have weapons out
and unfortunately for the decent humans
there are selfies this time there are
selfies yeah I actually saw a stealth
kill called a stealthy where you sneak
up behind a zombie pull your camera out
take a picture of you and Frank together
and then snap the zombies neck very very
dead rise goddamn
yeah they've also added like give an
exosuit now like a call of duty style
exosuit because why not rank in the
excess you can just run through hordes
of zombies and just like punch everyone
across the map which is already
hilarious but you can actually mod the
exosuit the same way you can mod a
vehicle so the demo I saw they actually
modded it with like a Slurpee machine
guy shoot tornadoes like purple and blue
tornadoes yeah you pretty much turned
into mr. freeze you turned into like the
Arnold Schwarzenegger version of mr.
freeze it's it's pretty great
so another thing that people that we
like dead rising one and two maybe more
than three which kind of went just like
the zany open world with crafting he had
like a steamroller motorcycle with Flame
Tree on the sides the timer is not
returning from the earlier games yeah
correct so your previous games had
several of those games that abandoned
the timer they would allow you to play
in like a separate mode but as far as I
can tell there isn't even going to be a
mode with the timer on it with the
exception of four player co-op online
mode so the campaign no time or
whatsoever does even smell like there's
gonna be an option for it but yeah at
least you can play it online if like
you're really devoted to that to that
aspect of the series did capcom tell you
anything about like the story we can
expect aside from the fact that it's
Frankie's photojournalists in wilmette
yeah so I guess this is a new outbreak
there was an outbreak on black friday so
it's basically the division maybe set
the same university nose for this some
kind of crossover coming up probably not
they haven't told us too much more but
Frank is once again in town to you know
uncover the conspiracy they did mention
there are a few new zombie types though
which I don't know if there's like a
story explanation for it but there are
now like evo zombies which are basically
I'm more highly evolved Dombey they're
smarter more agile they hunt in packs
the developers compared them to Raptors
basically like Jurassic Park style
Raptors and there are also what do they
call newly newly infected zombies which
are kind of like the 28 days later
zombies they're very fast they are
recently infected to the closer to
humans so they are not as like you know
grotesque or is like chamblee they
actually still have a lot of their like
strength and typically stuff that you
typically find
actual humans and they interestingly
will actually go around and bite
survivors so if you don't get to a
survivor fast enough you might see a
survivor turn into a newly infected you
will then come after you well it's
interesting you brought the survivors
because of people who played like three
and they're all the earlier games in
general you have the survivors you know
you kill a certain amount of zombies
around them to save him with four they
were saying that it's the same
geographical size as three but they're
kind of going deeper with it there are
more side quests and kind of like RPG
elements almost to pursue did they tell
you any more about how that's going to
be structured yeah they told me the same
thing not in much more detail but I
think it is interesting that they're
going to be more interior spaces there's
going to be more like verticality
buildings will have basements or you'll
be able to get on rooftops things like
that apparently more so than previous
games they also mentioned that the
layout of the overall world map will be
a little more consolidated in dead
rising 3 there were sort of like these
little islands of a world that you could
hang out and they were connected by long
strips of highway no more long strips of
highway there will be areas that are
kind of like longer and bigger and let
you build up some steam in your vehicles
and mo's amies down but you won't have
to commute through these really long
areas to get from place to place because
we're leaving Southern California thank
God yeah we're now back in snowy
colorado oh come on man you even like so
California you know like Nick Ramos in
real world I don't like so many
California oh
that is dead rising for we do have a few
gameplay videos up on the site and we do
have a few news stories coming out this
week from gamescom 2016 and until next
time stay tuned against body